called travel looks pretty exhausting so
maybe maybe you're staying home for the
holidays maybe that's a better decision
and my it might be and if you need a
little help
kitchen because it's a big
meat how about a little help from a
professional Aunt Candace Charles she
wants me to come to the house too look
at that maybe she'll come to your house
and help you out or not Candace good
morning what do you got for us today
Heather I'm a professional too I'm now a
chef thanks to these two guys these are
the real Chefs of course Katie Rizzo as
was Nicholas Rizzo thanks so much for
joining us this morning and our
wonderful Junior chefs say hi guys
oh are they so cute and they've learned
how to make multiple things from these
two wonderful chefs today we're going to
be making what we're making yeah so this
is called Pizza Frita
basically inside there is a sage and
it's the same dough as a pizza okay and
uh there is a little bit of sage and
then you have to fry okay that's it so
I'm Gonna Roll it out here right yeah
put one hand because I'm amazing
okay and then do a little bit just a
little tapping okay while she works on
that way Emily here works on that tell
us a little bit Katie about the services
you guys provide absolutely so uh we
have really started doing a lot of
cooking classes for all ages
um so we'll be doing a cooking course in
January for the kids all Italian cuisine
for eight weeks and then we also offer
uh adult classes as well so we can come
to you to your house and uh you can
learn anything from fresh pasta risotto
Pizza
um honestly really anything if you burn
water we can help you
um I love it I love it okay now Emily
you've learned a lot and now you're
putting what are these things you're
putting here on the pizza these
um we're putting ham
yeah what's your daily okay and then we
have a fresh burrata okay and then just
a little sprinkle of pistachio okay okay
you got to tell me Emily what has been
the best thing that you've made pizza
because he's
um the Rizzo's helped me and it was um
with amazing yummy pizza and it was the
best pizza ever best pizza ever I love
it I love it okay guys we're gonna give
this a try really quickly because it
looks delicious you know I like to eat
on TV of course you guys will get all
the details about the recipes and more
on the website newsnow.com and learn a
little bit more about the results we're
gonna do a little tasting guys let's do
a little tasting here we go
it was good good job Emily thank you now
from the home of Chef who's Wednesday
really really quickly happy holidays
family is so cute yeah I love that
thanks Candace thanks rizzos